for sure Brian asked me what is keeping
me motivated the answer is very simple
the first thing that I do enjoy
enormously relate to it and every day
there is something new something
exciting something butcher living I'm
challenging which is really very
exciting for me so I'm motivated because
I enjoy what I'm doing wish to be more
anymore everything with they were the
thing is that i'm not missing participa
like to envision i like to beat my
competition what I'd like to compete
against them and some time and came at
me guru so most of the time I enjoy it
and then I never feel frustrated even
when I go self-motivation something you
find it put in to yourself thank you